[Music]
[Music]
Curren exiles is an open world survival
game set in the universe of Robert E
Howard's Conan the Barbarian your first
moments in context are going to be
pretty rough cut down from a cross left
in the sand to die you need to find
yourself water then you can start
thinking on building it out a bowl with
arrows which will projectile weapon so
you can go hunting some of these
creatures are obvious and somewhat
mundane like elephants which you'll be
hunting for ivory
but then there's creatures that you'll
need silver to defeat and you'll need to
go and hunt those in the dark in haunted
places of high boria building is a very
important aspect of survival as well
having a building in conan Exiles
provides shelter from the environment
keeps you safe from the dangers of the
outside
and keep you safe your enemies in PvP
and of course it provides a place for
you to put all your stuff and lock up
behind closed doors but also another
very important tool that we have for
survival you make throws you create the
roles for example you capture a
blacksmith role and he'll give you
access to items that can only be crafted
by that blacksmith role that allows you
for example to create Sumerian weapons
even though your character is not a
Sumerian on the advantages of capturing
thrills and breaking their will on the
wheel of pain is it then you can use
them to defend your base when you're not
around your small private army of
thralls will be able to keep your stuff
protected while you're not there
[Music]
it is very important that you do prepare
for the sandstone because it will
ultimately kill you two options you can
either find shelter or you can craft
yourself a rebreather mask which will
allow you to survive and explore in the
sandstorm
as you explore the dark and dangerous
places of high boria it'll also start to
drive you insane you'll start to see
things and hear things that aren't there
but there are ways that you have to get
rid of it for example you can capture
and convert trolls that will dance for
you whose main effect is that they help
you get rid of your corruption religion
is another very important aspect of
survival as one of the major drivers for
conflict avatars are a major dominating
force in this world it takes a very
significant investment and when you
someone you can rest assured I'm going
to have a huge impact when you start
coming exiles you'll be scavenging
resources from the wasteland sticks and
storms to create your first rudimentary
axe but by the end you'll be summoning
an avatar of a God to smite your foes
regardless rival you better run
you